[Music]
this past week the senate unanimously
passed legislation that would officially
make juneteenth a federal holiday
and though some people celebrated this
news others see it
as a symbolic gesture in place of more
useful actions that the senate could
have taken
here with his unique perspective on the
situation
is our friend connor who means well but
you know mistakes will make you say yay
then what the hell
it's our friend connor who means well
but you know hey amber thanks for having
me happy belated juneteenth by the way
hey thanks connor uh for the white
people who like me
weren't aware of what juneteenth is it's
an annual celebration of june 19th 1865
the day that african americans in
galveston texas finally learned that
slavery had ended
many people didn't learn about this in
school i wonder why
now that you intense a federal holiday
it'll definitely be taught more in
schools
but if the senate thinks that erases the
need to take action against white
supremacy they're
fooling themselves juneteenth
wasn't the end of slavery in america the
system itself
is racist and until it's fixed black
people might as well still be slaves
making juneteenth a federal holiday is a
good decision but it's just a small step
we need to stop mass incarceration we
need to stop voter suppression
and we need to stop police violence
because if we can't fight police
violence
then we'll just have to fight the police
or or even better
make our own separate police force
entirely made of black people
here's a quote for you the white man
will try to satisfy us with symbolic
victories
rather than economic equity and real
justice you know who said that malcolm x
okay oh brother malcolm was spin
if they want to celebrate the end of
slavery how about they
actually end slavery no more prison
labor don't give
prisoners two dollars an hour to fight
fires give two dollars an hour to
actual firefighters or
or give the prisoners different jobs
maybe they should be police officers
that's that's one way to clear out all
the prisons turn all the bad guys into
the good guys
after all cops and criminals aren't too
far apart
our country was founded on racism and
violence
and although our government does its
best to convince you that we're
different
the only way actual change will come is
if we can pressure them to make it
that means calling your representatives
voting and telling others to vote
that means implementing anti-racist
actions into your everyday life
justice won't come from us recognizing
black people's suffering
it will come once we make the steps to
ensure that suffering will not continue
but i know and if we are committed we
can achieve that goal together
oh that's right yeah say that so let's
make america great again no
no next time connor comes on you need to
review his comments beforehand
i do thank you connor wakanda forever
amber
mistakes will make you say yay then what
the hell
it's our friend connor who means well
but you know
[Music]
you